do you still keep in touch by the way
with people from Nightmare and Elm
Street or any of the movies that you
worked on well yeah Amanda whis is
really one of my best friends and um she
and I in fact we're going to have lunch
next week so we keep really close
contact and then um Robert England of
course I see him a lot at shows movie
with him yeah he's great so he's you
know he's it makes me sad to see all of
us getting so much older because I in my
mind I don't feel like I'm getting older
but when we're all together we we really
like talk about it a lot like can you
believe 40 years has gone by you know
it's like so much time but so Robert is
a is I consider him a dear friend and
his wife Nancy ironically Nancy and then
um I see uh J Su Garcia um once in a
while but when we see like Ira heyen
from Nightmare 3 like we are in in touch
a lot right so Tuesday night night I
mean she's a good friend so Lisa Willcox
is a good friend this group of nightmare
actors we've been lucky that we've been
thrown together a lot going around the
country to these conventions and so our
friendships have really blossomed like
toy Newkirk I mean all these people like
I feel like are you know important
friends and and I could call them for
anything everybody's always said like I
asked around of course and they all said
she's so nice she's such a good person
you know Heather honestly I feel is that
a curse well no it's nice to be around
people that are like good like you hear
a lot of stories by the way was
Johnny Depp a nice guy back then such a
nice guy he was I'm sure he's a nice guy
now did you think he was going to be a
big movie star honestly no way I didn't
I mean because I didn't tell if I could
not tell if he liked acting or not
because he seemed kind of tortured by it
the pressure of I know that he really
worked hard to be you know Glenn and he
worked very hard on his part and so I
couldn't tell if he was enjoying himself
frankly I mean because he was always so
very dedicated and serious and you know
but you know we all joked around and
cracked smiles and stuff but he was a
musician he was a guitar player I knew
was in a band I thought oh he's just
going to go back to that because to sit
you know in a band behind a guitar and
play music is to me seems so thrilling
and like such a great thing to do to
able to play instrument like that I
thought oh he'll give this up this won't
this won't keep him you satisfied or
fulfilled if you're a great musician
you're not going to turn it all in for
acting you know yeah were you attracted
to him were you like oh he's cute he was
really cute you know he was married when
he did night Street yeah he was married
how old was he he was like 19 he had a
wife oh my gosh and I had a really
serious boyfriend but I mean he was
gorgeous he was gorgeous right yeah
gorgeous yeah wasn't a bad angle there
weren't not a bad angle
and and
yet he just didn't have that ego at all
so you didn't really he didn't you know
he didn't draw draw your attention to
him that him himself that way whereas
you know I had seen other actors like
I'd been around Matt Dylan and I'd been
around um you know some of those Brat
Pack guys and they all had this look at
me I'm so hot you know they had they had
that confidence because they'd all
become incredibly Successful by then and
Johnny didn't have that he was still
like kind of finding his place and you
know unsure of himself so to me that was
way more attractive of course because he
didn't have that crazy ego that I think
Hollywood made some pretty strong
egomaniacs back then too I would say so